سباق الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه يصل
الى اشواطه الاخيره والحزبان يحاولان حشد
كل الاصوات الممكنه والمرشحون في الولايات
المتحده والولايات الحاسمه فعليا هناك
استعانوا بشخصيات بارزه من احبابها في
الساعات الاخيره علهم يرجحون كفتهم على
حساب المنافسين في فلوريدا استعانه
المرشحون الجمهوريون برئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب الذي دعا الامريكيين للتصويت لانقاذ
الحلم الامريكي على حد وصفه ترامب اشارك
كذلك الا ان الحزب مستمر بتوسيعه قاعده
الجماهيريه خاصه في اوساط المواطنين من
ذوي الاصول اللاتينيه الذين كان اغلبهم
يصوتون للديموقراطيسيه
اماكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للولايات المتحده لدعم المرشحين في
حملاتهم الانتخابيه مره ظهر الرئيس
الاخير في فلوريدا ويوم امس توجهها الرئيس
الانتخابات يوم الثلاثاء نقطه التحول
ستحدد شكل البلاد في السنوات القادمه
سيختارون بين رؤيتين مختلفتين جوهريا
لامريكا
الموسم الموسم كامل